l'indonésie aurait refusé d'aller aux
termes d'un contrat d'achat de 11 avions
de combat sourrouille 35 d'une valeur
d'environ 1,1 milliard de dollars
même si pour l'instant moscou n'a reçu
aucune réponse officielle de la part de
jakarta cet accord avait été annoncée en
août 2017
l'indonésie prévoyait alors d'acquérir
les onze avions de chasse russe en
échange de l'achat par la russie de
produits tels que du caoutchouc de
l'huile de palme du café du thé ou
encore des épices jakarta envisagerait
maintenant l'achat de f 16 américains
voir du tout nouveau f 35 est la cause
de cette volte face la menace de
sanctions les états unis auraient
clairement indiqué que le gouvernement
indonésien risquer d'être pénalisé en
vertu de la loi 4 ça qui impose des
sanctions aux pays qui achètent entre
autres des armes aux entreprises russes
alors que les responsables indonésiens
n'ont pour l'heure pas commenter la
situation
l'ambassade de russie sur place a fait
part de son opinion et fustigé
l'extraterritorialité de ces sanctions
ce n'est pas un secret les états unis
exercent une pression non déguisée sur
les pays qui ont l'intention d'acheter
du matériel de défense russe l'objectif
est clair faire en sorte que ces pays
abandonnent leur contrat d'armement avec
la russie et se tournent plutôt vers
washington
c'est bien sûr de la concurrence
déloyale et même si certains pays
tiennent tête aux états unis comme
récemment la turquie avec l'achat du
système de défense s 400 ou comme l'inde
et l'egypte qui s'apprête à en faire de
même
la menace de sanctions ont refroidi bon
nombre de potentiels acheteurs
hélicoptère au mexique ou encore système
de défense antiaérienne au maroc sont
quelques exemples récents de cette
tentative de mainmise
alors simple lobbying ou concurrence
déloyale
moscou a toutes les raisons de penser
pour la seconde option